los cuerpos sin vida siguen llegando
incluso las diez morgues móviles están
alcanzando su tope tanto así que en el
paso texas los reclusos de las cárceles
fueron contratados para transportar las
pilas de muertos los hospitales están
llenos han tenido que transferir
pacientes y cerca de cinco mil
trabajadores de la salud adicionales
fueron desplegados en todo el estado
y texas no es la única jurisdicción con
un vertiginoso aumento de casos el virus
se está propagando en los 50 estados la
zona del medio oeste es la más afectada
sobre todo en los estados que siguen a
donald trump pues no se ha reforzado el
uso de tapabocas ni el distanciamiento
social ya que yo no creo que el virus
sea tan grave
ellos exageran lo agrandan más de lo que
es pero como en texas arizona tampoco ha
impuesto un mandato de uso de tapabocas
el gobernador le sugirió a los
residentes utilizarlos pero eso no duró
mucho por el choque de opiniones los que
lo apoyan y los que no one sight what's
the black aberdeen ground algunos
quieren un cierre total y por otro
algunos creen que todo es una farsa
poulter lauren bacall ambos grupos son
muy vocales la mayoría de las personas
no apoyan estas opiniones
con el uso de tapabocas a un politizado
eeuu superó el umbral de las 250.000
muertes por kobe 19 ahora tiene el rango
de muertes más alto del mundo a lo largo
del país las filas de pruebas de
diagnóstico son largas las últimas dos
semanas los casos se incrementaron en un
79% superando un millón de contagios en
tan sólo seis días